Australia is a country that is seemingly exists
to kill you.
Many of the world’s most venomous animals
live there, but, that might actually be a
good thing.
Recently scientists went hunting for these
guys, deadly funnel web spiders.
They captured three, brought the wee beasties
back to the lab and found something curious
in their venom that may have some surprising
medical benefits for humans.
Venom is bad.
Yes.
It’s evolutionarily designed to kill.
Mmm-Hmm.
And yet.
But, venom is also good.
Venom is a toxic cocktail of proteins and
peptides that precisely target molecules in
their victim’s.
Once venom hits the bloodstream it works quickly
to either thin the blood, block messages between
nerves and muscles, and/or some other awful
outcome that just does not end well for the
prey.
*evil look*
But, that’s because the spider’s just
trying to live!
It just wants to eat!
If you think of venom more objectively, there
are a number of peptides and enzymes in venom
itself that can be scientifically extracted
and used for good!
Scientists are hoping to isolate peptides
in animal toxins, synthesize and modify them
to treat diseases with no lethal side effects
… basically transforming venom from a weapon
into medicine.
Venom-based drugs have been in our medicine
cabinets for a while now.
Back in the late 1960s, a clinician discovered
a toxic peptide in the venom of the Brazilian
Pit Viper that happened to selectively inhibit
the action of angiotensin-converting enzyme
or ACE.
ACE is a chemical that plays a role in regulating
blood pressure by causing vessels to constrict.
This led to the development of a class of
drugs called ACE inhibitors, which are used
today to fight hypertension and congestive
heart failure.
Awesome, right?
Knowing that, think about what we could learn.
There are over 100,000 venomous creatures
out there, which means the possibilities for
future medical breakthroughs could be hiding
inside a predator’s lethal venom anywhere
on the planet!
Which brings us back to these funnel-web-hunting
scientists.
The scientists came across a similar breakthrough
by looking closely at funnel web spider venom.
It contains a peptide: Hi1a, that’s known
to “block acid-sensing ion channels in the
brain, which are key drivers of brain damage
after a stroke.”
To test it, they isolated Hi1a and gave it
to rats.
Then, they induced strokes in the rats, and
found that the Hi1a spider peptide protected
up to 77 percent of the rat’s brain cells
post-stroke!
Yay!
I mean it sucks for those rats, but it’s
a breakthrough for stroke research!
There are currently no drugs on the market
that can protect your brain if you have one,
so this is really promising.
And it’s not just snakes and spiders.
Scorpion toxins could treat autoimmune disease,
centipede venom could help with chronic pain,
and gila monster proteins might treat diabetes.
There are even deadly snails crawling along
the ocean floor filled with potent neurotoxins
-- and inside that neurotoxin is a peptide
that can reduce pain.
Scientists synthesized it into a painkiller
that is supposed to be 1,000 times more potent
than morphine.
Bottom line, we’re hardwired to be afraid
of snakes and spiders, but thanks to science
they’re saving huge numbers of lives every
day.
That doesn’t mean you should go out in your
backyard and catch a deadly snake thinking
you’ll find a cure for alzheimers … let
the crazy experts do that!
My dad used to say snakes were aliens.
No DAD.
But they are pretty weird.
How did they evolved to swallow things whole
for example?
We got the answers here:
Are you too freaked out by spiders to even
watch this video, I don’t know how you made
it this far, but tell us down in the comments,
make sure you subscribe for more Seeker and
thank you for watching.
One more thing happy birthday Lauren our new Associate Producer who wrote this episode.
Happy birthday!